scholar Johansen should star in a solo
black widow movie considering she made a
first appearance in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe before Thor Captain America
ant-man and the guardians of the galaxy
it seems like Black Widow is long
overdue for her own top-billed adventure
yet despite the fact that fans
overwhelmingly voted in favor of Widow
getting her own film over any other
supporting MCU character and the fact
that Johansson was named the
highest-grossing actress of all time in
2016
Marvel still hasn't announced the solar
project so why won't Marvel give Black
Widow a movie
Best Supporting superhero one of the
reasons Black Widow is so popular is
that she served as an excellent foil to
characters like Iron Man and Captain
America since her first MCU appearance
that's not to diminish her importance as
a character and hero in her own right
but if Marvel elevates Black Widow to
Top Billing status it'll be trickier for
her to come back to fill the hugely
important supporting role she's provided
not every character is built for
starring roles that's why we still
haven't gotten a movie based on Robin
solo adventures despite the fact that
he's one of the most recognizable
characters around he'll shrink it
grounded compare whether Avenger
colleagues Black Widow stands out as
underpowered Marvel movies showcased
characters doing amazing unbelievable
things often with the help of Super
Soldier Serum gamma rays sci-fi suits or
magic hammers but Black Widow works best
as a ground-level secret agent a black
widow spider maybe would be absolutely
awesome and could put any Jason Bourne
or James Bond adventure to shame but it
wouldn't really be a Marvel movie any
more than a rom-com would
old troll black widow you want to grab a
coffee I don't really have time to
dating guys now what about robots not
iconic enough they say a hero is only as
good as his or her villains so with that
in mind take a moment and think about
your favorite black widow villain who'd
you pick that's right probably no one
I like the rogues gallery that passed a
cap Thor an even Batman and Superman
there really are no awesome immediately
recognizable baddies for Black Widow to
fight while that weakness hasn't stopped
other superheroes from earning their own
movies it could be another reason
Marvel's waited to giver one toying with
fans summer blockbusters are often to
our toy bedsheet and backpack
commercials designed to sell merchandise
to as many kids and collectors as
possible so let's recall the controversy
from 2015 when Disney and Marvel decided
to largely exclude Black Widow from
Avengers age of Ultron toy lines and in
May 2016
news hit that Iron Man 3's villain was
switched from a female to a male before
filming began for one reason that toy
won't sell as well if it's a female what
you've just said is one of the most
insanely idiotic things I have ever
heard of course Disney also faced
massive backlash over this kind of
thinking over the company's decision to
under include Ray in the Star Wars
action figure line so maybe the
company's finally learned it's lesson
and that might help a Black Widow movie
action figures and all finally move
forward hope for Black Widow since 2007
Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige
answered to eccentric Marvel
Entertainment CEO Isaac Ike Perlmutter
who is so reclusive he reportedly wore a
fake mustache at the 2008 Iron Man
premiere like it was Bobby Valentine or
something Perlmutter was also reportedly
behind that I
three villain gender swap decision among
others but in August 2015 a little over
five years after Disney acquired Marvel
proper corporate reshuffling resulted in
Marvel Studios being directly absorbed
by Walt Disney Studios freeing Feige
from Perlmutter's control party so how
does that affect Black Widow fans it
means that Feige may be able to make
good on his comments from May of 2016
when he said that he was committed to a
solo Black Widow movie actually
happening sometime by 2020
after Walt Disney Studios absorbed
Marvel Studios he finally had the power
to put those plans into motion without
Perlmutter's interference whether or not
Johansson will still be available and
interested to take this movie on is
anybody's guess but for now the
possibility is greater than ever before
he is hoping it happens thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know why do you think Black
Widow should get a movie
[Music]